hello everyone
and welcome to today's webinar a novel
method
for quantitative western blotting that
eliminates errors
from the use of housekeeping proteins
i am michelle ashton of labrutz and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labrus
and brought to you by thermo fisher
scientific
to learn more visit thermofisher.com
let's get started
before we begin i would like to remind
everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate
by submitting as many questions as you
want and any time you want during the
presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions as you have time for
at the end of the presentation if you
have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation
click on the support tab found at the
top right of the presentation window
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab
located at the top right of the
presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits
i'd like to now present today's speaker
dr eloque
tamar product manager protein and cell
analysis
at thermo fisher scientific for a
complete biography on our speaker
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
alok you may now begin your presentation
welcome
um so thank you for that introduction so
today we are going to talk about an
exciting
uh webinar that we are doing uh which is
titled a normal method for quantitative
sustaining
that eliminates errors from the use of
housekeeping proteins
i am the product manager who is based
out of
carlsbad in sunny california uh and
carlsbad is the site where
there's no stain reagent that we are
going to talk about is made
along with our precast child
so this is uh basically a brief agenda
for today's webinar
so we will review the need for protein
normalization in
western blotting we will review data
generated using multiple cell lines
and popular target proteins with regards
to protein quantification
using two separate methods one with
using housekeeping proteins and
other with total protein normalization
and finally
we will review the benefits of using no
stain protein labeling reagent
for total protein normalization
so the most common method currently
being used for protein normalization
with western blotting is using the
housekeeping protein
the table here on the right lists the
most commonly used housekeeping proteins
that include proteins like actin
gap dh tubulin etc
the housekeeping proteins they are
assumed to be expressed
constitutively at the same level across
experiments
however recent studies have shown that
expression of housekeeping proteins
can change across different cell types
and biological conditions
therefore scientific publishers and
funding agencies
they now require other forms of
normalization
or validation of normalization controls
to ensure reproducibility and accuracy
of quantitative western blotting results
so this slide it demonstrates really one
of the biggest
issues with using housekeeping proteins
as loading control in quantitative
western blotting
so in this particular experiment hela
cell lysate
was loaded with increasing
concentrations
from 10 microgram to 50 microgram
the lysate was transferred onto a
membrane
and probed with one of the most commonly
used
housekeeping proteins so beta actin
gap dh and alpha tubulin
now since there is a linear increase in
protein concentration
from 10 20 30 40
to 50 microgram we should expect
a linear plot when quantitative signals
from this plot
so the ideal linear response is
represented by the dotted line
the gray dotted line on screen here
however
as you can see none of the housekeeping
proteins in helalysate
demonstrate that linear response the
reason
is signal saturation at protein
concentrations in this experiment
so by the way 20 to 40 micrograms of
lysate concentrations are pretty
standard in western blotting so this
lysate concentrations are not really out
of back or excesses
so take a look at beta actin blot and
the signal
intensity plotted in this chart
as you can see the signal intensity is
pretty much saturated
when you go from 10 to 20 microgram
lysate concentration
as a result you mostly get a flat
line when you plot those signal
intensities
which really means that when you're
looking at actin
there is not much of a difference
between 10 microgram load
or 50 microgram load which clearly is a
problem
gap dh and alpha tubulin they fare a
little better
at 10 and 20 microgram loads but there
is significant
signal saturation between 30 and 50
microgram loads
resulting rescues me resulting in almost
a flat line
at higher concentrations so in summary
um signals from housekeeping proteins
get saturated with increasing
concentration of elastic lysate
resulting in erroneous quantitative
results
so the question to ask is if the use of
housekeeping proteins
results in signal saturation an
erroneous result
which method would provide a linear
signal
so the answer is total protein
normalization and the reason is
total protein normalization is not
dependent on a single protein
i believe that is the reason why the
journal a journal of biological
chemistry
recommends that normalization of signal
intensity
to total protein loading is preferred
so actually total protein normalization
is beginning to be considered
as the gold standard for quantitative
western blotting
the prestigious journal nature
recommends
for quantitative comparisons appropriate
reagents
controls and imaging methods with
linear signal ranges should be used
similarly journal of biological
chemistry or jbc
recommend that normalizing signal
intensity
to total protein loading which can be
assessed by staining membranes for total
protein whenever possible
housekeeping proteins should not be used
for normalization
without evidence that manipulations do
not
affect expression now
it is really not easy to determine
in what cell lysate the manipulations
that are being used
are affecting housekeeping proteins in
which cell lysates
the concentrations that are being used
in an experiment
would result in signal saturation right
so
this recommendation from jbc that you
need to ensure
that the housekeeping protein works for
your experiment
means doing a lot of upfront work doing
a lot of validation
work to ensure there is no signal
saturation and there is no expression
level issues
for those housekeeping proteins so that
makes it really a challenge to continue
using housekeeping proteins
and total protein normalization would be
a much easier option
because of the concerns expressed by
these journals
now since total protein normalization is
becoming gold standard
we launched no stain protein labeling
reagent
with features that address the current
customer pain points
so the no stain protein labeling reagent
is flexible
and works with any protein gel that you
are currently using
whether precast or you are pouring your
own gel and any transfer membranes
that you might be currently using in the
lab the reagent has an
easy to use protocol with a labeling
time
of just 10 minutes the gel or the
membrane labeled with no stain reagent
can be visualized using a wide
range of images with uv green or blue
led
or fluorescence light sources the
reagent provides
accurate total protein normalization
results
with broad linear range for detection of
1 to up to
80 microgram of protein loads which is
really a very high protein load for a
gel to handle
the reagent is highly sensitive with a
detection limit of 20 nanogram per ton
with a stable signal compatible with
downstream
chemi and fluorescent antibody detection
so the no stain protein labeling reagent
it's a simple kit it contains
two bottles of labeling buffers that are
stored at room temperature
it has a vial of what we call as an
activator
and a while of what is known as a
derivatizers
and those two vials are stored at -20c
the protocol
is simple mix and add as shown in the
schematic
so you start by preparing 1x labeling
buffer
you add activator to that to add a
derivative
and you basically incubate the membrane
for 10 minutes in this solution there
are wash steps before and after
labeling to minimize any background
during
imaging the signal the nostril reagent
can be used to stain
also the gels or label the gels using a
very similar protocol
so it is a pretty simple reagent with a
very simple protocol
which gives you quick results quick and
rapid results
for your target proteins that can be
normalized using total protein
normalization
so in the next few slides um i'm going
to show you some compelling data
on why total protein normalization with
no stain reagent
provides very accurate quantitative
western blotting results
compared to housekeeping proteins so
this is the same experiment that i went
over
uh in slide four right so it is the hela
cell lysate with increasing protein
concentration
ranging from 10 to 50 microgram loaded
on the bold
bistress vegetable gel and transferred
using iblot 2 device
on a pvdf membrane the membrane was
labeled with no stain
protein labeling reagent this reagent is
a label
and not a stain because it forms a
covalent bond
with lysine amino acid and it has a
fluorescent tag
with an optimal excitation at 488
nanometer
and emission at 590 nanometer wavelength
so as you can see no strain labeled
membrane
it provides a linear signal over the
protein load
so from 10 to 50 microgram you can see a
linear increase
in signal intensity the signal intensity
was measured
and plotted and it tracks very close to
the ideal quantitative response
which is represented by the gray dotted
line in this graph
and that indicates that the signal from
low stain is
no stain is linear for the protein range
used
and it does not saturate the same no
stain labeled membrane
was then processed for immuno detection
of housekeeping proteins
beta actin gap dh and alpha tubulin
and as we have seen before the signal
from actin
really saturates quite early from 10 to
20 microgram range
and continues to be saturated up to 50
microgram resulting in a flat line
shown by the blue line here gap dh
you know slightly better at 10 to 20
microgram range
although still not linear and at between
30 to 50 that is again a complete
saturation
so the dark blue line with triangles
indicates that it is still mostly flat
at higher protein
ranges alpha tubulin similarly you know
slightly better response at 10 to 20
microgram
but at higher protein load there is
saturation which results in
getting a flatter line so as you can see
there is this clear limitation with
housekeeping proteins
where the protein loads are not properly
represented
but with no stain labeling reagent you
do get a linear response
throughout the range of protein lysate
which really results in
a very accurate quantitative western
blotting result
so next what we did was we did a more
numerically quantitative analysis of the
densitometric data that was presented
before
now this slide there is a lot more stat
in here but basically to simplify things
right
the larger the average of percent error
the less accurate is quantitation using
that particular method so in this
particular case you can see
actin has the largest
error percent of error
and what that means is that your
quantitative results
that you get out of actin uh are the
least accurate
gap dh fares better compared to actin
but again there is there is still
significantly higher error
and no stain you know although the ideal
result
would be 0.00 percent so no
percent error at all but that is usually
almost impossible to achieve uh in in
experimental
uh world uh so no stain there is uh
error of 4.4 percent
uh which is again really low and what
that means is
with no strain you are getting the best
quantification data using the protein
ranges that were used
in the healer cell lysates
so in the previous experiments with hela
cells right
we did not include a target protein now
most
researchers are normalizing
their target protein with either
housekeeping proteins or anything else
but it is always the target protein that
is the main interest
so in the next few set of experiments we
have included the target protein
so here the target protein is akt1
and this was done with cell lysates from
mcf7 cell lysate
just like in healer cells we have loaded
increasing
concentration of mcf cell lysate
on a bold gel so from 10 microgram all
the way up to 40 microgram
after transferring the protein onto a
pvdf membrane
the membrane is labeled with the no
stain protein labeling reagent
and again as you can see uh the signal
from 10 to 40 microgram
it does seem linear and proportional to
the protein load
we don't really see a saturation here
and when you plot this um again
which is the the green line over here
sorry the blue line in this particular
graph you are getting a linear signal
now akt1 which is the target protein
when you
use the ranges shown here from 10 to 40
microgram
this particular target protein because
you know expression levels are not as
high
as housekeeping proteins you are getting
a linear range of expression for akp1
here
which is shown by this green with
with the squares on it so both akt1 and
nostain have
a linear signal but again if you look at
the beta actin or gap d8 signal
intensities
and again this is the same membrane
probe with this housekeeping antibodies
you can see the signal saturation
happening from 20 all the way to 40
microgram for beta actin
and again 20 to 40 micrograms for gap dh
so you are getting this sort of a flat
line
for gap dh and then beta acting later
but again you know if you look at there
is no
difference between 20 and 40 microgram
load
which is obviously a problem and that's
why result
from these housekeeping proteins are not
accurate while results
from no stain gives much more accurate
quantitation with akt1
target proteins here so here
again we looked at the percent error to
predict response
uh from this particular experiment
and again as you can see the percent
error for no stain was significantly
lower
compared to beta actin and gap dh
which further highlights the accuracy of
no steam based quantification
in mcf7 cell extract as well when using
akt1
as target protein so if you look at the
numbers here again
as i said you know 0.0 would be the
perfect result
no stain is at 5.8 so
slightly higher than the target result
but
if you look at actin and gab dh you know
they are
several fold higher in terms of the
error and so you know compared to no
stain
they do provide much more erroneous
results
so this is again a new set of
experiments so here what we did is
we took the jerker's cell lysate and we
looked at a different target
protein cyclophilin b
again the results are remarkably similar
that even with increasing protein
concentration no stain based
total protein normalization provides a
linear signal
the target protein cyclophilin b also
shows
a very very linear signal but the
housekeeping proteins
beta actin and gap dh are saturated
resulting in a non non linear plot
right so again as you can see the
results are very
fairly obvious you know even if you
don't look at the plot
just the image itself shows that no
stain
has pretty linear signal which
corresponds to
increasing protein loads but if you look
at the housekeeping proteins you know
beta actin
from 10 to 40 it almost seems there is
no difference
in protein load so at 10 microgram
you're almost getting a complete
saturation
same thing is true for the fdh right
even at 10 microgram which is not that
high of
the lysate load you are getting a
complete saturation
so really there is no difference between
loading 10 microgram or 40 microgram
and the plots they really represent that
they are
almost flat and that again would give
completely erroneous results when you
are trying to normalize your
cyclophyllin b
which is really linear at the ranges
used here
for the jacket for lysate
now the percent error plot again
demonstrates that
normalization of cyclofluid b with no
stain provides
accurate results compared to beta actin
and gap dh
which gets saturated with increasing
protein loads and results in
erroneous quantification of cyclophilin
b you know just looking at the values
uh you know the no stain percent error
value is slightly higher here 13.5
percent so it's the first time
we we've seen no stain in the
double-digit territory if you will
but beta acting you know it's close to
56 percent and gap ds is at again you
know 50
right so you know there is some error
inherent in this particular experiment
but
with housekeeping proteins the error is
really so high
that it is almost impossible to get
accurate quantification results with
that
but total protein or ppm is still within
acceptable range and would provide
an accurate quantification result with
cyclophile and b
in in-jerked cell extract
now to assess data that might be more
representative
of the kind of results sort by
researchers
studying biochemical signaling pathways
we compared
a quantification of target proteins from
a431 cell extract
that had been treated with human
egf epidermal growth factor to untreated
a431 cell extracts our findings are
illustrated in this figure as already
demonstrated with other cell lines
the no stain reagent exhibits superior
capability
for protein organization compared to the
housekeeping protein
in the case of a431 cells
the housekeeping protein beta actin
shows virtually
no densitometric signal response to
changing protein levels
and would therefore not enable any
protein normalization in the system
the no strained and systematic signal
intensities on the other hand
show a linear increase with protein load
and
track closely with target protein levels
in both treated and untreated a431 cell
extract
the non-linear behavior of the hkp
signal intensity
or signal saturation further conforms
with this a431 extracts that accurate
protein normalization
cannot be achieved with housekeeping
protein beta actin
under tested conditions uh so again
right this this data set is also
uh very powerful uh as you can see
with treated and untreated you know you
see phosphoegfr levels when they are
treated with
human epidermal growth factor but you
don't see that
when the cells are untreated and then
here's the egfr levels with increasing
light concentrations followed by
by beta active levels at the bottom is
the membrane
probe or labeled with the no stain
reagent
although visually things are pretty
clear but it's always good to look at
the graphical representation
that no stain and egfr they both have
linear signals right
so you know the fact that the target
protein
in all of these conditions that we have
talked about today
and all of the the lysate ranges that we
have talked about today you know the
target proteins
give a linear signal right which means
we are not really
overloading the system we are not really
overloading
the gels uh to make beta actin
saturate in this particular case so we
are using the lysic concentrations that
are typically used by researchers
and making sure that the target proteins
are not saturated in those ranges
which is the case in all those
experiments but if you look at signals
from housekeeping proteins
they are really saturated pretty early
on right at 10 microgram
loads which is not that high so if you
look at
the expression level of egfr at 10
microgram
you know it is quite faint so if you
load less
to make sure your acting does not get
saturated
you would not see your target protein at
all right so that becomes a challenge
so the reason for that this are the
practical
loads because you want to see your
target protein first
but at that protein concentrations your
housekeeping proteins
are almost always are going to be
saturated and
we have shown this with different cell
lysates and different target proteins
and obviously we can't include every
cell lysate in this particular study
but you know we feel confident that this
is going to be repeated
in in more lysates when we try and
reproduce this set of data
so you know whether you are labeling or
whether you are
you know treating it with egf or not
treating it
you are getting the same results linear
curves from no stain and your target
protein egfr
whereas saturated data from your
housekeeping protein
which in this case is active so actin
really would not be able to justify
quantitative western blotting with egfr
in in this particular cell lysate as
well
so again in this slide we are looking at
the percent error of method calculations
which further demonstrates that in
untreated and treated conditions
protein normalization of egfr and
phosphorus gfr
can be accurately done with no strain
reagent
but not with housekeeping protein which
in this case was b-backed in
now another cool thing about the no-skin
reagent is right
all of the data that we just reviewed we
were labeling
the membrane after transfer right so
it was a membrane it was working as a
membrane label
and that labeled membrane was then used
for total protein normalization
but this reagent works really well for
labeling
proteins in the gels also right
so here's the data which demonstrates
its ability to label protein in the gel
so in this experiment we loaded
increasing protein concentration of cell
lysate from 2.5 microgram
all the way up to 80 microgram so again
80 microgram is a really heavy protein
load
and we you know after gel
electrophoresis
this gel was then labeled using the no
stain protein labeling reagent
and as you can see at even at lower
protein concentrations of 2.5 microgram
you are able to see a lot of band pretty
distinctively
but at 5 microgram you know again
all of the bands are pretty clear and as
the
protein load increases uh you really
don't see
a saturation right so you do see a
proportional increase
in signal intensity uh with labeling of
uh
no strain reagent and when we plot this
in the graph over here what we are
seeing
is we are seeing a linear signal with no
strain reagent
from 2.5 microgram all the way up to 80
microgram
and it corresponds to this ideal dotted
line
concentration curve that you can see
here
so you know the message here really is
that
the no stain labeling reagent works
really well for labeling proteins
in the gels and it can be linear
for a very long range of protein
concentration similar to what we
saw with labeling of membranes
in the previous data sets
so now this slide really provides the
ordering information
for most n reagents so the reagent comes
in
two different sizes in a regular pack of
40 reaction
and a sample pack of 10 reactions the
web link provided here
thermofisher.com no stain
it has how to use videos for no stain
and then normalize it using the eyebrite
imager
it has an app note on how to use no
stain and hybrid imager for total
protein normalization
and it also has a web form to request
free samples of no stain
and the website contains additional
information about total protein
normalization
that you might find helpful so do visit
that website
and you know use use it for
the nice giveaways we have in there as
well as educational material
that you would find really helpful
and finally you know the eyebright
imaging system is the most ideal for
total protein normalization
using the no strain reagent the eyebrite
imager
which is pictured here it looks really
nice
it's very functional it has a built-in
nostain mode
that makes it a breeze to capture images
of gels and membranes
labeled with no strain reagent and
followed by
total protein normalization by using a
proprietary normalization software
that is included with the imager
so that was my life last slide thank you
very much for
attending this webinar today and i will
be happy
to take any questions you might have
thank you you ello for your informative
presentation
we'll now start the live q a session of
the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please
do so now just click on the ask a
question
box located on the far left of your
screen
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for
all right let's go ahead and get started
your first
question is what are you using for
quantitation of
signal intensity and what types of
secondary
uh yeah so that is a great question
so in this particular case we are
using the eyebrite images for acquiring
the images
as well as normalizing it using
the software that the albright imager
has for protein normalization
but you know there is enough flexibility
where
you can use any software that you might
be currently using
for quantitative western blotting so for
example
image j which is a free software also
works
really well for for that purposes as
well as any other
software that enable that kind of
quantification
would work in terms of the secondary
antibodies used here
so we have used the fluorescent
secondary antibodies in this experiment
um so again if your imager allows for
the ability to multiplex which eyebrite
does
then you know it offers that option of
using fluorescent antibodies
for looking at multiple targets within
the same blood
we were using the ir and far
ir alexa floor secondary antibodies
because you know just one channel which
is
uh emission at 488 and excitation at
590. so that one channel
uh is taken by the no stain signal
but then there are other channels with
ir and
rir range which can be used for
secondary antibodies to do multiplexing
great thank you okay the specs user says
i have a question regarding the
linear increase on slide four how
precise
does linearity need to be would alpha
tubulin between
10 and 20 microliters be fine
uh yeah so i think that's another great
question right so i think it really
depends on your
particular experiment uh so for example
you know there are experiments where
researchers are comparing differences
between a
phosphor protein and a non-phosphor
protein
after treatment with a agent that
triggers phosphorylation now in those
experiments
even a small difference between treated
and untreated
is going to be extremely critical right
so for experiments like that
where you know even a 10 to 15 percent
difference
uh would considered as a
very significant result for that
particular signaling pathway
it is really important that the signal
is really linear right
as close to perfect as it can get
because you know if you are going to
have
conclusions about 5 to 15
increase in phosphorylation levels as an
important signaling event
then you need to be really sure that
that increase is real
and that can only be ensured if you have
complete linearity with your
normalization
method right so for such experiments i
would say
that you know the housekeeping protein
would not be sufficient but you know
there might be other
set of experiments where a small
variability might be okay right
so i think it depends on the experiments
you're doing
but you know to be safe and to make sure
that your
results are really accurate it does make
sense to use a method
that really gives linear results to
begin with
is no stain compatible with lycor
itis odyssey
um so yeah i mean i'm not very familiar
with
the capabilities of leica like odyssey
imager but no stain basically has
an um you know emission and excitation
so you know it can be excited
at 488 and you know
the emission is at 590. so as long as
your imager is capable of of
doing that then yes there would be
a compatibility with that
great thank you now your next question
is a two-part question
is it possible to strip the labeling
reagent
after probing for another analysis and
can we cut the membrane to evaluate
multiple proteins with the same membrane
yeah so you know great question again um
so
with regards to the no stain labeling
reagent right so
this is a tag that binds to the lysine
amino acid
covalently so the way this tag works is
you're supposed to probe your membrane
before blocking right so blocking buffer
typically has proteins
so you don't want to label all the
proteins in your blocking buffer also
so you have to probe the membrane with
no stain before blocking
but once you once you probe the membrane
there is a covalent bond that forms
between the nose stain reagent
and the lysine amino acids which is
really stable
and you can then process that membrane
for all of your immunodetection
experiments
so you can use that membrane and you
know you can go forward with your
blocking step
you know primary antibody secondary
antibody and detection whether you're
using a cami
or a fluorescent based methods it really
doesn't matter
this is compatible with all of that
downstream workflow right
so with no stain you would not you would
not have a need to really strip
that signal from your protein
because again you know it's compatible
with everything downstream and it would
not interfere
you know as long as you're using the
right and secondary antibodies which
does not overlap with the signal of no
stain
and yes you can absolutely cut the
membrane
and probe it with different targets
what you can do is either you can take
image of the entire membrane up front
after labeling or if you want you can
you know wait till your
entire experiment is done uh immuno
detection
followed by you know the whole detection
method
and you can image along with your target
protein so it has that flexibility
because the signal is stable and would
last throughout your experimental
condition
thank you okay your next question how
can you use it within an
actual western blot experiment
uh yeah so that is something that i just
i think i
talked about it couple of times uh but
just to
briefly you know go over it again
what you would do is after your transfer
is done no matter what your actual
experiment is
after you finish your transfer you would
take that membrane
and you know probe it with no strain
labeling reagent
you can then after probing you can take
an image
right away or if you want you can then
go forward with your entire experiment
of blocking primary antibody secondary
antibody
so on followed by detection and then you
can take
images at the end of the nostain
signal as well as your target protein
signals
and the no stain signal is stable
and it will last throughout your
experimental process
so you have the flexibility of doing it
either ways
thank you okay your next question alok
does the intensity of no stain protein
labeling reagent
change only with the protein load
or are there other factors that can
influence this
as well um
so yeah i mean again you know great
question again uh
so the signal that you get from
no stain labeling is really proportional
to the protein load right so all the
data that we showed today
you know there was ranges from 2.5
microgram all the way to 80 microgram
and you saw that
you know the signal intensity really
represented
the protein load in there so you know it
is representative of what's being loaded
and
it stays linear with increasing protein
loads
there can be some factors you know like
you know background
with any fluorescent method there is
always a possibility that depending upon
how you have labeled and you know how
you process
that that whole labeling thing what kind
of background you are getting
so you know if there is uneven
background in the membrane for some
reason which typically does not happen
then there is a possibility that the
background can add some variability
to your signal so that that is
one other method that i can see where
there can be some variability
um through this experiment but again the
probability of that happening is pretty
low
if you just follow the steps of the
protocol and include the wash steps
before and after
you know labeling with no stain so these
are two minutes wash with
with water really um so again convenient
way to process
uh but it's important as the steps are
followed so we don't have any background
issues and there are no really
variabilities
to the actual signal that is coming from
a labeling of proteins with no stain
thank you now how are the signals of
protein bands
measured with the nostain gels
so yeah great question i think i
answered this earlier on
for this set of experiments we are using
the hybrid imager and the analysis
software
that comes with typewrite imager uh for
quantitating
the signal from from no stain reagents
so basically
you select the lane you know every well
is going to be a separate lane so you
select that lane and
the software would give you the signal
intensity
coming out of label proteins for that
particular plane
so you know that that densitometric
signal is then used
to to normalize the results that were
presented here
now after no seeing protein labeling
reagent
can i use fluorescent secondary
antibodies
red and green without any problems
uh yeah so yeah good good question again
right so
as i said no stain is a fluorescent
probe
uh which has an excitation at 488 and
emission at 590 right
so obviously you would not be able to
use a fluorescent secondary antibody
that also has an emission at 590. but
you know there is a range of
fluorescent secondary antibodies at ir
and
ir ranges uh you know with
with emission at 700 750 800 and so on
and all of those can be used for
multiplexing um
along with no stain so the the data set
that was presented here
uh we did use uh you know all of the
secondary antibodies were fluorescent
secondary antibodies
um in ir and fire for ir ranges
so we were multiplexing with fluorescent
secondary antibodies in
all the data that was presented today so
yes
fluorescent antibodies can be used uh
with no stain
the only thing to keep in mind is make
sure you are not using something
that is that is an emission at 590.
thank you now do you have any data from
immune cells
uh so immune cells is not something so
we did not
include uh any immune cell lysates in
the experiments that we have done
uh so far um so yeah right now i would
say yeah we don't have
any data from the immune cells at this
point
now can this no stain reagent work or be
used with proteins made from
plants yes absolutely so
the way the no strain reagent works is
that
you know it is uh an fq label
uh that gets activated when you mix the
activator and derivatizer together
right so it has no signal
till you mix the activator and
derivative together but once you mix
them together the fq label gets
activated
and that label has a pretty high
affinity for the lysine amino acid
so lysine amino acid is really the most
abundant
amino acid in in proteins um you know
so there are hardly any protein that
does not contain lysine
whether it's animal or plant or
or even a bacterial so yeah it works
with
all protein types and the intensity and
sensitivity
uh irrespective of the source of
proteins is pretty high
with the nostalgia labeling reagent
now what if we do not have the eyebrite
and major are there any other methods we
can use
yeah so you know the the labeling you
can
you can really excite and image it
with using a wide range of wide range of
images right so if you have
any other images that you are currently
using for example
for taking images of either
fluorescently
probed labels uh or even your cami blots
right if you have
images that are able to excite within
the uv range
and then capture the images at 590
all of those images would work right so
images with
with uv capabilities with blue or green
led lights
are of course fluorescent images that
whole wide range of images
are compatible with imaging signals from
no string labeled membrane examples
thanks alok and i do want to remind the
audience any questions that we do not
get to
today we will follow up with you via
email after the webinar
okay your next question what is exactly
exactly measured to normalize the
results from a given
band do you measure the whole lane or
the band where the protein of interest
is yeah so for total protein
normalization right so again
that's a great question so the total
protein normalization the reason
why that method is really linear
is that you know you are not reliant on
a single protein
with single protein there are chances
that one protein
can show saturation depending upon the
expression level
but when we are measuring signal from
the entire lane
uh then you know that is a method that
ensures that
uh the signal stays linear um for a wide
range of protein load
um so in all of the experiments
presented today
when we are talking about normalizing
the entire load
we are measuring uh
signal from the entire well and not just
a single band
when we are measuring the target protein
or
housekeeping proteins that is the only
time when we are measuring signal from
that specific band and plotting it
great thank you after using the product
can i do the stripping easily or are
there some specific stripping buffers
that should be used
uh so yeah like i said before right with
this particular
reagent you really don't need to
stress uh the signal you know again the
reason being that
it is compatible with the downstream
western application so we wanted
this to be as easy as possible
for the current western workflow you
know stripping and reprobing again adds
additional multiple steps and sometimes
you know strip shipping buffers can be a
little harsh
which can which can kind of compromise
immunogenicity of the target proteins as
well
so we we don't recommend stripping this
particular signal
for downstream western applications for
those reasons
so you know again you know if you want
to strip
it would work the same way as it works
with when you're stripping
your antibodies because antibodies also
form a covalent signal with the target
protein and the stripping buffers
are harsh enough to break that covalent
bond um
to remove that signal so if you want to
uh
your typical stripping buffers would
work but that's not something that we
recommend
with this reagent because we feel it
just adds extra workload
and time for processing of western
blotting and
not really needed with this no strain
reagent
thank you we have time for just a few
more questions
does the probe attach to more than one
lysine in a protein
yes so that's a great question also
every protein has you know obviously
multiple lysine residues
because it is one of the most abundant
amino acid within a protein
so in our experience you know we feel
this reagent binds to about 30 percent
of lysine recipes in a protein
so it doesn't bind to every single
lysine in a protein
but it does bind to about 30 which is
still
uh you know a good number of lysine
residues uh to make sure that the signal
is strong
and the detection limit is pretty high
for this reagent
great thank you now how
do you go about no stain normalization
if the transfer has not been even
throughout the whole membrane
so you know the question really is that
you know for some reason what you loaded
on your gel
is not evenly transferred onto the
membrane you know which would indicate
that there is a problem with the
transfer
method or the transfer efficiency
because you know typically
what you load on your gel should be
reflected
uh on your membrane as well right so
that uniformity should be there in your
transfer method
so you know if there is a problem with
that then obviously
what the no strain reagent is going to
do it is just going to detect
the amount of protein that is present in
every well post transfer
so if there is a difference in that
uniformity
then you are going to see difference in
the signal also
but typically you know that does not
happen
during the transfer process if your
transfer has worked well
the amount of protein you load on your
gel is going to be reflected
on your membrane also and then the no
strain will just tell you
what is the signal strength in
every individual well on your membrane
thank you so much now can the reagent
interfere
with the antigen recognition of the
target protein
yeah so that's a that's a very good
question so
with the way this labels protein labels
work is you know obviously they are
binding to lysine amino acids
specifically
so now if your target protein
has lysine in the antibody detection
pocket
then there is a chance that there is
going to be some interference
in detecting that particular target
protein now because lysine is so
ubiquitous
you know what we have found is you know
most antibodies
when they are trying to look for a
unique signature
they try to avoid this most common amino
acids right so
most target proteins really don't have
lysine in the
antibody binding pocket but again you
know
there are certain targets that we have
seen
where you know there would be some
interference
because of this now those those are very
few
and far but it is really possible that
depending upon your target protein
it would be good for you to analyze if
there is
any kind of interference or not you know
before
adopting it completely for for that
particular experiment
but what we have seen is that even if
there is uh some interference
all it does it you know reduces the
signal by
a very small margin which is
hard to detect unless you are comparing
an experiment where
you run you know an experiment without
no stain and experiment with no stain
and do a side by side comparison and
quantitate all of it
you might be able to see some difference
in in for some target proteins
but again for most target proteins it's
not going to be an issue and
it could really not not matter in terms
of
the results that you're getting with
that because it would uniformly affect
the membrane
it's not really specific for any single
protein
thank you it looks like we have time for
one more question
if my primary antibody detects lysine
will the nostain interfere with my
targets
so would i need to use no stain at the
end
uh yeah so i mean that's that's a great
question um
answer the second part first right so
for you to label
a membrane uh the only time you can
label a membrane is before you add your
blocking buffer
uh to the membrane or antibodies also
right because this
is a probe that detects uh proteins um
so again you know
blocking buffer has proteins your
antibodies are proteins
so it is going to detect everything um
if you try to use it
after probing it with your antibodies
and and you know your western workflow
per se so that cannot be done this has
to be done
before blocking buffer step right um so
you know now if your target protein is
identifying lysines only so antibodies
identify glycines only
for that particular target protein you
know there is
a possibility that there would be
interference with this
as i said uh this probe binds to about
30 percent of lysines
so you know not necessarily uh
it would specifically target that
antibody binding pocket
but again because it's binding lysine
there is a probability that
you would see some diminished signal
from your antibody
so you would have to really test it out
in your experimental system and see what
kind of interference you're getting and
is that interference
significant enough uh to block the
signal uh
to a level where you know your signal is
really low and then you can't use this
reagent right so
that is something that you would have to
test it out
thank you so much ello do you have any
final comments for
our audience before we go today
um yeah so you know very exciting
questions from the audience um you know
great interest so
just glad to see that uh there is
interest about
uh saturation of housekeeping proteins
which is really the most commonly used
method right now
and all i would like to say finally is
that nostril really offers
a great alternative to housekeeping
proteins
it is simpler faster and accurate right
so you if you don't
probe for housekeeping proteins um you
know you are you're saving all of
those antibodies you're saving all of
those steps uh that are required to
probe the target protein and then
process them
uh so this is really a great alternative
it simplifies your workflow
and enables you an ability to to get
very accurate
quantitative western blotting results so
i would say you know if you are
interested you know please go to
thermofisher.com
webpage where you can order you know
samples free samples
we'll be happy to send it out to you so
that you can test it with
your target proteins and experimental
system and you can see for yourself you
know
how this is going to make your western
blotting results
much more accurate and also convenient
at the end of the day
so i would like to thank you once again
for
all the exciting questions and listening
to the webinar today
and hopefully this helps you with your
experiments within the lab
thank you eloq for your time today and
your important research
we would also like to thank labruz and
our sponsor thermo fisher scientific for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their questions
again any questions we did not have time
for today and those submitted during the
on-demand period
will be addressed by a lo via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand and
labberts will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's
live event until next time goodbye